I'm so excited it's pretty cool to be in
the Marvel World especially with a
character that's not so known Sony
Spider-Man universe is ready to reopen
in 2024 with the release of the weirder
Wilder and woman Centric spin-off manam
web based on a somewhat obscure Marvel
Comics character the film will introduce
audiences to Mystical Oracle Cassandra
Webb an elderly blind Ally of the webbed
wall crawler who uses her powers of
Clairvoyance to see into his future Sony
has made some significant changes to the
character for the upcoming movie casting
30 something actor Dakota Johnson in the
title role Madame Webb will be joined by
quite a talented cast which includes
such names as Celeste o Conor Emma
Roberts and Adam Scott Sydney Sweeney
was recently confirmed to be playing
Julia Carpenter Marvel's second
Spiderwoman in the character's live
action debut the little is known about
the plot at this stage Sony is hoping
for another success when it lands in
theaters on February 14th 2024